DeSantis is going after Trump like never
before this is a CNN story
uh uh uh let's see here so Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis now Canada for
president has openly criticized foreign
calling him fiscally irresponsible a
supporter of amnesty for undocumented
immigrants and blaming him for
destructive covid-19 policies DeSantis
aims to flex the powers of the
presidency like never before intending
to fire Trump's handicapped FBI director
Chris Ray on his first day if elected he
believes Trump has changed since his
2015-2016 campaign and asks questions I
don't know what happened to Donald Trump
The Scientist by the way that's a very
good strategy DeSantis plans to push the
limits on the executive branch using his
knowledge of the Constitution leverage
points and the true scope of
presidential powers to accomplish the
schools he wants to discipline the
bureaucracy dispel the notion of
independent agencies and issue pardons
for cases involving political targeting
of open weaponization so check this out
that whole concept of I don't know what
happened to Donald Trump of 2016 2015
he said the other day one of the things
he's been talking about is Trump keeps
going further left oh yeah Trump keeps
going further left I actually think
that's powerful to make that statement
and in shows in Florida Dead Heat race
between DeSantis and Trump Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and former
president Donald Trump are tied in a
neck and neck contest among likely GOP
Primary voters in Florida according to
recent poll conducted by Victory
insights DeSantis narrowly leads with
38.2 percent while Trump follows closely
at 38 percent in a head-to-head matchup
between the Santas and Trump the
governor holds a slightly stronger
position with just over 40 percent
compared to Trump 39 the poster senior
poster Ben galbright acknowledges the
uncertainty regarding the durability of
those results He suggests that the
scientists surge in the post maybe
temporary reaction to his campaign
launch or it could slightly it could
signify signify the beginning of a
successful campaign the outcome of the
denomination May change on Florida
Republican voters as a leaked audio from
donor meeting reveals the importance of
winning the state's winner takes off
presidential preference primary schedule
for March 19th of next year what do you
think of when you see this Myron
foreign
it's crazy man because it's going to
cause divide
um I think the thing is is that you know
the census obviously is very uh people
love them down here in Florida but I
don't know if the rest of the country
knows about him like that so
um yeah I I wish they would they would
collaborate and work together and uh you
know take over the Biden Administration
but you know that's not going to happen
because now at this point it's kind of
in the court of public appeals and
they've been making fun of each other
and you know Trump's been poking fun at
him so yeah we're past that but do you
think that they can't do what the what
the Democrats do we talked about this
the last podcast Biden and Kamala went
at it but right when it was done he's
like I love you vice president there's
zero chance that that happens if Trump
wins because they're not going to go the
other way around it's possible but not
not probable is what I is what I think
just because it's been kind of them just
on each other the whole time
and even even Trump's been he's been
going pretty hard at DeSantis and so
yeah and Kamala was never on Biden's
level I mean she was of course she was
punching up he was like all right cool
whatever I gotta I gotta cross off a
African-American woman to make her vice
president you're one of four people that
are candidates and if you kiss the ring
so to speak I'll give that was a
political move exactly there's a
political move that's what he did
something of definition she's is not
African-American right so well
yeah sure by the way have you ever seen
Kamala when she was dating Montel
Williams a monster went to an event with
two women gangster being one of them
have you seen it yeah yeah
was with her and another girl and went
to an event look at that Pam look at
that pimp well listen uh chilling look
there's many pictures on the internet
with me and two girls that doesn't mean
I mean obviously you're not the vice
president no you're not a Kamala Harris
that's uh and uh you know Montel when
Montel was running the number one by the
way what's so funny is is that a cross
he's wearing is that a soul I think it's
a sword okay I was gonna say it's
actually probably it's a cross sword
it's probably one of those cocaine uh
sifters let me just unplug it it gives
some Cruel Intentions can I say one
thing about DeSantis
um
it's interesting because I don't think
there's there's going to be some
cohesion there I think that's I think
that's I wish I wish too I think that's
too far gone it was interesting I was I
watched the Heat game but I was shout
out to the heat
um uh I was watching it was game five it
was a few nights ago I was with all my
buddies from that I grew up with in
Miami you've known these guys yeah yeah
all um this segment of my of my friends
they're all liberals all of them okay so
safe space yeah safe space so I come in
late you know because I was working late
that day and I walk in they're like oh
look who's here Mr Maga Mr right wing
I'm like so it just shows like as a
registered independent like you can't
win these days no if I go into right
wing circles I'm the soy boy I'm the I'm
the leftist the Communist and if I go
into left-wing circles I'm the mag I'm
the Trump I was like listen guys there's
no way relax for a second but I said is
anybody here a trump fan no Trump
trump I go all right
um
none of these guys are voting in the
Republican primary but I know I get this
is anecdotal but I said all right
uh if you had to choose between Trump
and DeSantis who would you vote for 10
guys okay these are never trumpers what
do you think the results of my internal
poll was eight to two DeSantis I was in
six seven three
six four seven three this answers to
Trump okay Trump trump seven the same
yeah three Tom uh I'm gonna go also six
four to Santa it was split down the
middle oh God so just for some
perspective these guys who never I have
to meet these guys yeah because at this
point I'm not I'm not sure
they're telling you they do and they
would never in a million years vote for
Trump but that's in their mind how low
does Santa says well and they're all
Florida Miami-Dade guys but you know
well I think this is popular here in
Florida but I just don't know if the
rest of the country is gonna you know it
knows who he is or cares you know
obviously Trump is the more polarizing
figure he's you know he he's more
marketable right and Trump did a
fantastic job when he campaigned before
make America great again you know
because they didn't understand that you
know being a president is advertising
you know making fun of Hillary lock her
up you know crooked Hillary Etc like all
these memorable moments do you have all
any of these like memorable moments with
these other guys like Obama when he
campaign change right like he was real
big on Words yes we can so um the the
presidents that typically win especially
in in the social media age are the
better marketers they say that um you
know for every business you either have
a uh product problem or a marketing
problem I think we know what Ron
DeSantis problem is it's a marketing
problem and my trump don't got that
problem yeah it might be made a good
point because like the the country
doesn't really know who DeSantis is yeah
but the left has put out those little
markers of don't say gay Bill he hates
gays and the NAACP just put out that
thing that said warning don't come here
because they're actively going after
black people it's like come on boys so
the country knows of him as being
Florida as being like like a Nazi don't
like don't come here you know what I
mean and all these polls that are behind
all of this this is right now what we
have is they are pop activity polls
right you have a little activity and you
have a pop you have a little activity
you're gonna have a drop so you're gonna
have a little activity pop little
activity drop and that's why my victory
insights pollster Ben Galbraith was
saying hey we really don't know about
the durability of the pole what he's
saying that the durability of it is like
hey three weeks from now somebody's
going to make a little verbal Gaff and
then it's going to pop the other way
Americans aren't going to wake up and be
really pullable mark my words until the
morning after the Collegiate national
championship game that way all New
Year's is over all the all the games the
ball's over and we're into the serious
part of the year I believe we're going
to be in the recession there and the
people are going to wake up and go wait
a minute we really get it we really have
to do this and you're going to have Iowa
South Carolina New Hampshire lining
right up until then we're going to see
pup and Drop pop and Drop pop and drop
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you
[Music]